you've seen get log output a few times
now and you know that it doesn't
necessarily always show you every commit
so how does get logged figure out which
commits to show you it turns out that
each commit knows about its parent that
is it stores a reference to the commit
that was checked out when it was made if
you were on a branch when you made the
commit it still just stores the commit
ID of what was then the tip of the
branch the commit doesn't care anything
about branch names only the branches
themselves store anything about the
position of the branches to make it
really clear what info is actually
stored by git I'll include arrows in our
diagram to show each commits parent this
will become more important once we get
to merging but it's good practice to
start thinking of commits as having
parents now all right back to the
question of git log log starts with the
current commit or the latest commit of
any branch or branches that are
specified and traces back until it gets
to a commit it doesn't have a parent
this will generally be the initial
commit this leads us to the concept of
reach ability you can see that in our
diagram there are some commits say this
one that can't be reached by other
commits say this one there's no way to
get from here to here suppose we checked
out this commit remember that we mark
this with a star and then we made a new
commit from there which would move head
or the checked out commit to here if you
then checked out an existing branch to
say a master then the commit that you
just made would be lost unless you
happen to have written down the commit
ID since it's not actually reachable by
any of the current branches to drive
home this concept we've created a
fictional diagram we've used shortened
get like commit IDs to label each commit
and we've just used letters to label the
branches given this diagram if I ran git
log for each of branch a and B which
commits would be listed list the commits
by their shortened IDs from most to
least recent and separate them with
commas all so are there any unreachable
commits in this diagram if so list them
here